this is the tesseract it has the
potential energy to wipe out the planet
what does fury want me to do swallow it
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is going
to be all my Captain Marvel Easter eggs
from the movie there were all kinds of
90s jokes and references including
Easter eggs for internal stuff within
the MCU going back to the first Avengers
movie paying off a lot of big set ups
from way way back we'll do a new round
to the imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a Marvel comment on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet or maybe you haven't seen
it and you don't care and you just want
to know what all the Easter eggs are so
we'll work our way down the list there
are a little over 20 of these starting
at the beginning of the movie working
away to the end with the Stan Lee intro
Thank You Stan
the edited Stan Lee's cameos in all of
the scenes of him inside the MCU as well
as some external scenes of him with the
actors just showing how important he is
to Marvel Studios and what they became
today it was a really touching memorial
to him but that wasn't the Stan Lee
cameo that's a completely separate scene
number 2 welcome back blockbuster
obviously blockbuster a big staple of
the 90s now there is only one
blockbuster left in the United States
she crashes right through the roof she
blows Arnold Schwarzenegger's head off
of a True Lies standees she picks up the
right stuff movie she notices hook as
she walks past the movie aisle
bangarang then she goes outside asked
the security guard about finding some
gear he points her to RadioShack also a
big staple of the 90s they're still
around but not quite as big the minute
she hits Earth though they start up with
some of the 90s music references they
played what a man by salt-n-pepa only
happy when it rains by garbage
Waterfalls by TLC come-as-you-are by
Nirvana just a girl by no doubt that was
probably the song that I hated the most
not a big fan of no doubt or Gwen
Stefani celebrity skin by hole and man
in the moon by REM the Stan Lee cameo
was great it was actually really meta
because it's Stan Lee in real life on
the train on his way to film a scene for
Mallrats which technically is not his
first Marvel cameo but it is his first
movie cameo talking about Marvel stuff
so that's what he gets credit for 8
a really cool scene it also works really
well too because the cameo that Stanley
is doing is cameo as himself in real
life and that's also what he did in the
Mallrats movie he was playing himself
during that movie Kelly soo Taconic the
writer of the Captain Marvel arced that
they adapted for the movie hire further
faster had a brief cameo in the subway
station she brushes past her looks at
her she's a woman with red hair but if
you blink you will miss it there were so
many jokes about 90s computers in the
90s version of the internet being super
slow dial-up internet AltaVista she sits
down at the computer and it boots are
off because the line is busy then later
in the movie they have the joke about
the disk spinning up to access the
information and it takes forever because
it is slow as hell she uses Gameboy
parts to repurpose a communicator to
call the Kree to tell them to come back
to Planet Earth and pick her up then
when they're at the dive bar there's a
street fight or two arcade cabinet in
the background she pulls a terminator -
when she steals Rob Kaczynski's bike she
grabs the Nine Inch Nails t-shirt off of
the mannequin the funny thing about it
is that that's actually a bootleg
t-shirt that they had to make for the
movie because they couldn't get an
original one when Nick Fury is telling
her about his personal history he talks
about all the places he went during the
Cold War
he named Budapest Budapest is a place
that has been mentioned or seen a couple
different times in the MCU we also find
out that his middle name is nicholas
joseph fury but even his mother calls
him fury if i ever have children
they'll call me fury - we find out the
origin of the special Captain Marvel
soup tub space pager at the end of
Avengers infinity war in that
post-credits scene is just regular Nick
Fury's pager that he uses for shield
business that Carole then repurposes one
of the really big changes they made from
the comics is that Walter Lawson aka
Marvel original Captain Marvel from the
comics is Wendy Lawson they gender bent
her and for the purposes of the MCU she
is now a Kree scientist working
undercover trying to use the tesseract
to build a faster than light engine the
really cool thing about that is that she
gets the tesseract and helps found
project Pegasus which got mentioned way
back during Iron Man 2 I've already done
a couple videos about that with the help
of Tony Stark's father Howard Stark so
Howard Stark built project Pegasus
because ever since World War two he's
been in possession of the tesseract
when Wendy Lawson came along for project
Pegasus he gave the tesseract to her to
try and study we don't know whether or
not Howard Stark knew that she was an
alien but he's pretty smart so it's
implied that he was working with her
because she was a relatively good person
she was helping hide all those scroll
refugees so she couldn't have been that
bad that's how the tesseract got into
her ship in outer space a lot of
questions about how it went from Howard
Stark to wendy lawson basically sometime
in the late 80s he handed it off to her
that's when she got it Nick Fury drops a
great laser tag reference when he's
making fun of her costume Monica Rambeau
is a big character during the movie
obviously big comic-book character we
don't know if they're gonna turn her
into a superhero or an Avenger in a
future movie it kind of seems like based
on the ending of the movie they
foreshadow that but she's talking to her
mother she drops all kinds of 90s
references talking about watching Fresh
Prince of bel-air instead of going to
help Carol when Monica Rambeau is
helping play with the colors of her
costume they cycle through a couple
different comic book costumes one of
them is the white and green costume that
the original Captain Marvel Marvel
walter lawson wore when he first debuted
in the comics this is a super deep cut
she cycles do another one that's Nova
colored making her look kind of like the
Nova superhero of the comics she cycles
to the black and gray one that she wore
in the comics for a little while then
she cycles to the red blue and gold one
that she's been wearing for the last
several years in the comics there's so
many goofs the cat references they put a
Hannibal Lecter mask on him and Nick
Fury even calls him Hannibal Lecter
there's a whole bunch of Secret Invasion
Easter eggs the Skrulls stay why can't
we stay on planet earth we could live
here they say it wouldn't be safe for us
Kevin Feige actually directly talked
about the secret invasion storyline of
it all they did say that these scrolls
are just the good ones and just like any
other space based race there are good
people and there are bad people within
their species so there's just him
leaving the door open saying yeah we'll
probably do some sort of secret invasion
storyline in the future with evil
Scrolls but he didn't say when that
would happen there's a couple different
Sam Jackson pull fiction references when
he's writing with Coulson in the car is
just like them riding in the car to go
get the briefcase when Talos walks into
the house drinking that drink is just
like Sam Jackson drinking the drink
during Pulp Fiction that was a tasty
beverage probably one of the biggest
Easter eggs is just how she got her
powers
like I said Wendy Lawson aka Marvel from
the comics was experimenting on the
tesseract to make a faster than light
engine that energy blew up infused
Captain Marvel so she gets her powers in
the very similar manner to the way that
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver got their
powers from the mine gem only captain
Marvel's come from the space stone there
was all kinds of 90s pop culture inside
Marvel's research ship there was the
nerf gun that mint irva tries to shoot
Captain Marvel with not understanding
what a nerf gun is there's Happy Days
stuff there's troll dolls pretty much
every kitschy thing that you could have
collected during the 90s the call signs
were also a really big deal too so her
friend Maria Rambo's call scientist
Photon that's one of the superhero names
that Monica Rambeau her daughter takes
in the comics when she gets her
superpowers but also probably the
biggest retroactive Easter Egg is isn't
giving Captain Marvel the callsign
Avenger that was her callsign when she
was a pilot so at the end of the movie
when Nick Fury is drafting up what is
his first draft of the Avengers
initiative he's calling it the protector
initiative but then looks at the picture
of her sees that her call sign says
Avenger and gets the idea to call it the
Avengers initiative so Captain Marvel is
the inspiration for the name of the
Avengers but it's very important to note
that nobody in the movie at any point
ever calls Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
so they'll probably do that during
avengers endgame the supreme
intelligence big comic book character we
never actually got a look at its true
form and because it's still alive at the
end of the movie I'm assuming that
they're gonna bring it back as a
character in a future space based movie
maybe the Captain Marvel sequel like
Ronan the accuser says that he's going
to come back for the weapon the woman so
very clearly he's going to come back in
the sequel and be a bigger villain jaan
raghav villain and still alive at the
end of the movie so he'll probably be a
bigger villain in a Captain Marvel
sequel the way they explained the MCU
supreme intelligence is that it's not an
organism it's actually an artificial
intelligence that when it's talking to
you will take the form of someone that
you admire which is why it looked like
Marvel when she was talking to it gusta
Kat is a fleur kin from the comics
they're just basically have this giant
mock and consume anything goose eating
the tesseract then throwing it up in
that last post-credit scene obviously a
very funny moment big
but it's also a callback to a line of
dialogue that the Hulk had during the
first Avengers movie so like there were
a lot of moments tying this to the
original Avengers so that when she shows
up it'll be like oh wow you were kind of
the inspiration for a lot of this stuff
but the funny Avengers reference is when
the Hulk is talking about the tesseract
going crazy he talks about it being able
to destroy the entire earth what does
fury want me to do swallow it
just like goose the cat swallowed the
tesseract the hook could probably
swallow it and survive but the tesseract
and the space stone actually have a
consciousness so if it didn't want to
have itself swallowed by the Hulk it
could transport him somewhere else just
like the Red Skull the obvious Avengers
endgame post-credit scene is her showing
up at the Avengers facilities sometimes
shortly after the snap because cap still
has his beard but he's had a shower and
they're a little cleaned up black widows
hair is still really short ant-man
hasn't shown up in his van as far as we
know but the interesting thing too is
the reason why she's so quiet is
probably just for the twist her costume
looks a little bit different but it's
been 20 years I've already done a
post-credits scene video talking about
that so I'll link that at the end of
this I'm sure there's a billion more 90s
references in the movie if there's any
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments or any
other big Easter eggs what'll happen is
is there'll be a couple more Marvel
videos this week a lot of Avengers
endgame stuff coming up leave all your
video requests in the comments below
click here for my Captain Marvel
post-credit scene video and click here
to rewatch the avengers endgame trailer
a billion more times thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]